A donde está más grande dolor, donde está. El suegro, mamá, mis cuñados, estaban ya
conmigo, ya hallaron todo, tenía yo ser que podían vivir. No era muy fácil. El homenidad
es egoísmo. Se olvidan que uno hizo para uno. ¿Usted me entiende? El llama a mi hermano
y dice, mi querido yerno, yo era fundador de esta cerradera, desde todo, verdad mire,
que tu hermano yo de nera, ahorita yo soy jefe, con Colobert, era muy amigo de él,
muy amigo de él, que su hermano deja 12,5% menos. Mire, una cosa que yo te voy a decir
una cosa, que yo no soy hombre por las puyas, entonces consta mi hermano. Mi querida hermana
sabe una cosa, yo soy Itzik Meyagaes, mi nombre es el nieto Fingero el Rebe, el sabio.
Yo regalo tu suegro todo, yo no quiero nada. Mi hermano, ¿qué estás haciendo? Yo digo
y cumple no quiero más. Cuando yo vine para casa y dije mi señora esta y mi suegro, empezaron
todos a llorar, que usted no sabe, ¿por qué lloraron? Nos citaban Arbeitskart, ¿qué significa?
Documento que estamos trabajando, que no están trabajando, llevan a la migración, para trabajo,
en agua hasta acá, secar campos para sembrar y hacer ríos. Entonces yo contesto así mire,
yo no quiero saber de nada, en mi vida yo no pido a nadie favores y discusiones, así
es y así es. Mi señora era muy fina, muy fina, entonces dice papayito, ¿qué voy a hacer?
Lo voy a apelar con mi esposo. Yo no soy flojo, agarro un polaco, me voy para Evitechna, yo
conocí un profesor y me dijo así mire, tomo dinero, vaya para Lublin, yo te doy una carta,
compre mi cuero, cosas para hacer negocio, vender gentes, para tomar plata. Se puso más alegre del mundo,
que ya no era profesor, ya no era colegio, ya no era nada y fui para Lublin, ciudad,
segundo ciudad de Polonia, Varsovia, Lublin. De mi ciudad a Lublin era 75 kilómetros.
Él me trajo una carta, y esta señora, que me dijo siempre cómo yo hice dinero, y que me dio un beso aquí.
Estoy muy alegre que están con vida, nosotros sufrimos mucho, ya estamos cerrados, ya estamos en el año 40,
ya no estamos en el año 59. Estamos en ghetto, no podemos hacer correspondencia, no hay correo.
Él me trajo cuero para zapatos, cosas, jabones, yo salí a la ciudad, vendió, salió muy poco.
En año, fin de año 41, llega un señor.
Pero en todo ese transcurso, ¿qué ha pasado? ¿Hay nuevas medidas con los judíos? ¿Los judíos pueden hacer esto, lo otro?
No me tengo, yo te voy a explicar.
Llegó un señor de Lublin, que quería hablar conmigo.
Tu negocio de tablas para Lublin, que alemanes dan permisos para botar tablas allá.
Yo oí todo, y dijo, ¿tú tienes permisos? Dice yo, por otra hora. Listo.
¿Cómo se llamaba ese señor?
Littenberg. Littenberg.
En ese momento, señor, Aktia, ciudad.
¿Sabes qué es Aktia?
Alemanes agarraron 100 judíos y llevaron para su víboro.
¿Eso en qué momento fue? ¿En qué año?
En el año 40.
¿En qué época? ¿En qué mes?
Pasó en septiembre.
Y allá empezaron a hacer la cosa.
Ya se viene todo el mundo, ya cada uno ya pasó.
¿Qué puede usted me dar? La cosa como era.
Y uno de allá, todo era con hambre, electricidad, no podían salir.
Dominado con electricidad.
¿En dónde?
En su víboro.
¿Cómo sabe usted eso?
Un momento. Como yo sé. Uno huyó de esas 100 personas desnudo.
Y regresó para la ciudad, y ya dijo, ¿qué está pasando allá?
Que están preparando un crematorio para los judíos.
Estas 100 personas, porque él huyó, no quemaron.
Octubia no era el horno.
Con vapna, ¿cómo se llama? Con cal, cal.
Cuando se hace cemento, hay un cal.
Este se pone, y se echa gasolina, y sí.
Electricidad.
Era primero 99 personas encima de nosotros.
Después, ya hicieron un crematorio.
La viola, que es una cosa muy larga.
Y este hombre dijo todo lo que es.
¿Cómo se llamaba él?
Ah, no puede ser.
Mires, señora, señorita.
Y la ciudad se puso negro.
Después de esto, ya puso el Judrat.
¿Sabe qué es un rat?
Judrat, por ejemplo, es un gobierno de 100 personas.
Y que el jefe de SES.
Necesita una cosa, tiene esa comisión.
¿Quiénes conformaron el Judrat?
El jefe, primero, él se llamaba Nitschke.
De SES.
¿Envolvía?
Envolvía, todo envolvía.
Y hablamos, todo envolvía.
Olvídate.
Ya.
Un día.
En el año 41.
Otra acción.
Ya sabía antes qué iba a pasar.
Entonces, en esa heladera donde yo salía de allá, que era mi hermano.
Era un búnker.
Yo escondí a mi mamá.
Yo, mi hermano, mi suegro, mi cuñado, y mismo a mi hija.
Ahí va.
El Golovitz, el ciego, era fiel.
Nunca iba a decir que algo él tenía que esconder.
Llevaron, primeros, 1500 personas al local de cena.
Tenían 24 horas.
Y mandaron para Kametoya.
Allá, ya se quemaron.
No con vapna.
Ya, quemaron.
Como yo sé que se quemaron,
en camino, cuando llevaron, enfermaron.
1500 personas.
Ya sabía dónde iban.
Entonces, llevaron polacos con caballos, con cabezas,
y metieron, ya.
Ahí entraron y salieron de allá.
Entonces, allá, ya dijo que trabajaban también polacos allá,
para no matarlos.
Dijeron que ya está.
No, no.
No se modificaron.
No.